Chevrolet yeah
Chevy has won the race to build the
first mass-market long-range affordable
electric car that's the bolt
it's got 200 miles of range and it'll
cost less than $30,000 when it hits the
market later this year overall the bolt
feels a little like flying economy class
on a brand new state-of-the-art plane
you've got screen and outlet to plug in
your phone and off legroom and some
sleek appointments Bluetooth connects
automatically as you approach the car
the bolt recognizes individual keys so
it knows who's driving and twos the
radio accordingly there are enough
cupholders and that's the whole idea the
bolt isn't supposed to be some
over-the-top science fiction future a
luxury car it's a Chevy it's supposed to
be practical affordable and comfortable
it's supposed to be a car you shouldn't
mind spending a lot of time in it does
all those things and it doesn't really
well and it just happens to the electric